en projet de loi qui nous concerne c'est
sur public sénat ravi de vous retrouver
sur public sénat dans un instant
l'examen du projet de loi sur la réforme
de la poste va reprendre dans
l'hémicycle du sénat les sénateurs vont
poursuivre la discussion générale qu'ils
ont entamé hier soir ils ont déjà pris
beaucoup de retard
mais le début de cette séance va surtout
être marquée par le dépôt d'une motion
référendaire par le groupe socialiste
les verts les communistes et le groupe
rdse du sénat
c'est une motion référendaire qui
demande donc un référendum sur le
changement de statut de la poste c'est
en vertu de l'application de l'article
11 de la constitution qui prévoit que le
président de la république peut
soumettre au référendum sur proposition
du gouvernement ou sur proposition
conjointe des deux assemblées
un projet de loi relatif à la politique
économique ou social ou aux services
publics de la nation il faut également
rappeler qu'il y à une votation
citoyenne qui a réuni près de 2 millions
de personnes qui étaient invités à se
prononcer pour ou contre le changement
de statut de la poste est bien pour les
sénateurs de l'opposition
il est il leur est apparu indispensable
que cet attachement constaté à
l'occasion de cette votation citoyenne
se concrétise par voie référendaire
il faut également préciser que si cette
motion est déposée cet après-midi en
sciences elle ne sera examinée que
demain mercredi après-midi tout de suite
donc direction à l'hémicycle bonne
séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi relatif à
l'entreprise publique la poste et aux
activités postales
j'informe le sénat qu en application de
l'article 11 de la constitution et de
l'article 27 du règlement sur les
présidents présidente jean pierre bel
nicole borvo cohen seat yvon que la et
plusieurs de nos collègues présents une
motion tendant à proposer au président
de la république de soumettre au
référendum le projet de loi relatif à
l'entreprise publique la poste et aux
activités postales en application de
l'alinéa 1er de l'article 67 du
règlement cette motion doit être signée
par au moins 30 sénateurs dont la
présence est constatée par appel nominal
constatation qui sera fait par deux
secrétaires du sénat qui vont prendre
leurs postes respectifs notamment madame
de messine est dit monsieur françois
fortassin
donc mais que chaque havre rejoint son
poste
je vais demander à monsieur l'huissier
de wierre faire procéder à l'appel
nominal madame alquier jacqueline madame
andré michel monsieur andréoni serge
monsieur angèle bernard monsieur
assouline david monsieur le président
bayle jean-pierre monsieur bérit-débat
claude monsieur berthou jacques madame
blandin marie-christine madame blondin
maryvonne monsieur bodin yannick madame
bonne foi nicole monsieur fautrel
yannick monsieur bourquin martial madame
bourzai bernadette monsieur boutant
michel madame aubry qu nicole madame
cartron françoise monsieur cazaux
bernard monsieur collombat pierre-yves
monsieur d'audignies yves un monsieur
d'aunis marque
monsieur de mejia jean-pierre monsieur
desessard jean monsieur dos mais elle
claude madame durieux josette monsieur
fisher jean-luc monsieur frécon
jean-claude monsieur frimas bernard
monsieur gautier charles madame gallix
amiens monsieur godefroy jean-pierre
monsieur guillaume didier
monsieur o claude monsieur hervé edmond
madame hervio odette madame jarraud
vergnolle amie madame khiari bariza
monsieur krattinger yves monsieur la
gauche serge monsieur le maine jacky
madame le texier raymonde madame lepage
claudine monsieur lozach jean jacques
monsieur marc françois monsieur mation
marque
monsieur mickaël gérard monsieur
mirassou jean-jacques madame nicoud rené
monsieur pastor jean-marc monsieur
patients georges monsieur patriat
françois madame prise
gisèle monsieur raynaud marcel monsieur
raoul daniel monsieur rebsamen françois
monsieur sergent michel monsieur sutour
simon madame tasca catherine monsieur
testons michel monsieur teulade rené
monsieur young richard monsieur le
président colin yvon monsieur tropéano
robert monsieur charasse michel mais ce
baye laye
monsieur mézard jacques monsieur
fortassin françois madame escoffier
anne-marie monsieur me aux gens monsieur
chevènement jean-pierre madame la
présidente borvo cohen seat nicole
madame assassi eliane madame beaufils
marie france monsieur bio michel madame
pasquet isabelle monsieur d'anglo
jean-claude madame david a ni madame de
messine michel madame didier evelyne
monsieur le président fischer dit
monsieur urbain
monsieur le cam gérard madame terrade
odette madame à mathon josiane madame
gonthier-maurin brigitte monsieur khalid
jacques monsieur renard yvan madame
cherche mireille monsieur verra bernard
monsieur voguer jean-françois monsieur
autun françois
il est merveilleux
bien ac et donner du dépôt de cette
motion
lorsque les secrétaires me confirme la
discussion de cette motion
oui après cette annonce fin d'année par
reprographie pour la photographie donc
la discussion de cette motion pour avoir
lieu demain matin mercredi 4 novembre
bon s'il vous plaît je pense que vous
m'écoutez derrière vos feuilles de 9h30
à 12h30
par analogie avec les propositions de
loi la discussion de la motion débutera
par l'intervention de l'un des auteurs
de la motion 20 minutes maximum
quel est celui qui défendra pour 20
minutes je me tourne vers le président
belle madame borvo cohen seat mii
chocolat c'est le président bayle qui
donc voilà la commission pourra ensuite
exprimé son avis sur le texte de la
motion de même que le gouvernement en
accord avec les groupes
le temps des groupes sera déterminé à la
proportionnelle du temps donc réparti
les inscriptions devant être faite au
service de la science pour que nous
ayons un débat ordonnée et non
reprographes y est avant aujourd'hui 18
heures le gouvernement pourra le cas
échéant naturellement répondre aux
orateurs monsieur le ministre
le sénat se prononcera alors je vous le
rappelle par un seul vote sur le texte
de la motion et par un scrutin public
ordinaire
pour l'heure nous allons poursuivre la
discussion du projet de loi sur la poste
la parole est maintenant dans la suite
de notre discussion générale à monsieur
jacques blanc pour le groupe ump
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
sur président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues dans ce débat passionné
ouverts par des consultations dans des
urnes de la rue qui se prolonge même à
l'instant par une motion référendaire le
travail exceptionnel de la commission
des affaires économiques
monsieur le président emorine et
monsieur le rapporteur est riche à ce
travail formidable que vous avez
accompli avec l'accord du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre nous permet me
semble-t-il de prendre un peu de hauteur
et de suivre par là l'appel de la poste
dont l'emblème ne l'oublions pas est un
oiseau bleu qui bat pavillon sur les
vélos jaunes ou les casquettes des
postiers est aujourd'hui sur l'hérault
nos jeunes des postiers c'est oiseau
bleu c'est aussi partie de l'histoire
commune des français de leur vie
quotidienne et j'en serais même le dire
fait partie de notre identité nationale
il est le fleuron d'un bloc non
négociable des services publics de
proximité qui permet d'assurer le lien
entre nous tous et vous permettrait aux
médecins de lozère que je suis qui a
accompagné des postiers dans la neige
qui sait
ce que ces postiers qui sait ce que
c'est portier cet oiseau bleu représente
dans le tissu social de notre pays
permettez moi de dire oui que cet oiseau
a servi de messager portant dans son bec
les missiles les cartes postales les
bonnes mais aussi les mauvaises
nouvelles
c'est lui qui mène à la guerre a
réchauffé le coeur de nos combattants et
de leurs familles c'est lui encore qui
parfois apporter la nouvelle du drame
dans ces familles dans des hameaux
isolés mais où l'arrivée du secteur
représente quelque chose alors personne
n'a le monopole du coeur pour les
poussières ou les banquiers oui notre
coeur bat avec celui d'un potentiel et
les postiers alors de quoi s'agit-il
aujourd'hui et nous n'avons pas le droit
de les tromper ou de les utiliser à des
fins politiciennes
voilà ce que je voulais dire à l'instant
mes chers collègues en effet de quoi
parlons nous dans ce texte il s'agit de
quoi il s'agit de permettre à la poste
oiseau bleu
non pas de le plomber mais au contraire
de lui permettre d'aller de l'avant avec
un cap qui soient tracées
il s'agit de l'alléger pour qu'ils
puissent voler plus haut plus loin et
plus vite au service de l'ensemble de la
population car ya des faits dont vous
êtes responsables comme nous tous
excusez-moi l'ouverture de la
concurrence au 1er janvier 2011
elle a été voulue par tous les
gouvernements de gauche comme de droite
de france d'europe et du monde et qui
peut prétendre
qui peut prétendre qu'il peut y avoir
une activité de postes
si ce n'est pas ouvert sur l'europe et
sur le monde et donc ce sont des faits
alors où on cultive le passé où on
trompe les poussières et les postiers où
on trompe les femmes et les hommes
d'autres pays où on prend le taureau par
les cornes on essaie de trouver des
solutions
c'est ce que vous avez fait dans votre
gouvernement monsieur le bis car chacun
sait bien que face à cette ouverture où
il y aura la concurrence elle est
incontournable
face à l'évolution du haut débit de
l'internet et à la baisse d'activité que
personne ne peut contester ou on se
croise les bras et on dira ne fera rien
où on ose dire il faut harvey la poste
c'est ce que vous faites avec un statut
des capitaux les 2 milliards 500
millions dont ils ont besoin dans le
respect d'une double ambition permettre
à la poste de rester ce qu'elle est une
très grande entreprise qui compte dans
le monde et dont on peut être fier
même s'il ya de temps en temps quelques
problèmes
et répondre aux exigences d'une
entreprise de service public grâce au
travail de la commission à la volonté du
gouvernement
nous allons inscrire dans la loi que le
capital restera public qui c'est un plus
grâce à la volonté et à l'action de la
commission
on va pouvoir répondre et garder et
garder les objectifs d'un service au
public service au public qui se définit
et qui est repris dans la loi
donc on modernise et on garde les
racines on modernise en garde une
réponse d'exigence de présence
territoriale d'universalité
personne ne nous croient mais excusez
moi regarder ce qui se passe dans le
monde entier
alors moi je dis ici mes chers collègues
je dis ici que nous voulons sauver ce
service public garde l université garder
un capital public garder des exigences
de présence territoriale
oui 17 villes au point ce sera désormais
elle free dans la loi oui renforcer la
capacité de partenariat et sacem faudra
encore trois minutes mon cher que les
nationaux si on me regarde pas
je peux pas donc il faut arrêter là
quand du bon il faut garder la capacité
d'un partenariat
ces agences municipales postale c'est
une bonne réponse
encore faut-il peut-être qu'on regarde
le statut des agents et en parallèle aux
agences municipales postale jeu proposé
j'ai reçu des représentants des postiers
à la canourgue la semaine ça me dis
qu'est ce que je leur ai dit je vais
suggérer que en même temps qu'il peut y
avoir des agences postales ou des
activités commerciales avec l'activité
postale
pourquoi dans des bureaux de poste qui
ont évité un peu limite
ne pourrait-on pas associés aux
activités postales menée par ses bureaux
de poste des activités de partenariat
avec erdf france télécom munications ou
d'autres il faut que le paralyse
et je dis à mes possibles de lozère que
je porterai ce message aux états car je
suis sûr qu'au delà des vociférations ou
du jeu tout le monde est bien conscient
que si on ne bouge pas on condamnera
l'avenir même de la poste
vous avez obtenu des crédits importants
pour le fonds de compensation
c'est une sécurité pour ses dix sept
mille postes et vous maintenez la règle
des 20 minutes ou 5 km mais attendez
sauf peut-être dans certains endroits où
il faudra qu'on négocie avec des accords
à l'unanimité et oui j'ose dire que
parfois il ya des points où il faudra
qu'on discutait à l'unanimité de tous
les élus parce que sur le terrain
droite et gauche on descend tous la
poste quoi là vers la réalité
vous n'avez pas le monopole du coeur je
vous le dis alors rené cher collègue
il est important il est important que
prenant de la hauteur et suivants
l'oiseau bleu on sorte de cette attitude
qui n'est pas très digne parce que les
fausses consultations
ça peut mettre en cause les vrais
consultation et vous allez discréditer
les référendums par une attitude quand
vous savez que personne ne veut de la
privatisation de la poste
il est quand même facile et d'interroger
les gens qui défend ici la privatisation
de la poste
alors mes chers collègues montrons que
nous voulons nous représentants des
territoires ruraux
möller conclure oui mais le silence
allez-y
s'il vous plaît non pas quelques minutes
j'avais encore 30 secondes est remonté
nous voulons un service dans le cas de
monopole le président soit un service
universel unicité tarifaire sur le
territoire et distribution six jours sur
sept livraisons de la presse sur tout le
territoire présence territoriale avec
dix sept vélos points l'accessibilité
bancaire alors c'est un dossier qui
était passionné difficile mais grâce au
travail de la commission et à l'accord
du gouvernement
nous sommes fiers de sauver ici le
service public d'abord merci mon cher
collègue bien nous arrange les cartons
jaunes et nous passons à madame evelyne
didier pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
la parole mais chers collègues mes chers
collègues nous allons peut-être revenir
à des arguments monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je concentrerai mon
intervention sur le défi du maintien de
la présence postale selon les termes
mêmes de l'étude d'impact sur ce projet
de loi le gouvernement se trouve en
effet dans une situation paradoxale
comment faire croire que la présence
postale va se trouver renforcée alors
même que la transformation de la poste
en société anonyme va la contraindre à
une plus grande rentabilité économique
indépendamment de son utilité sociale je
vous rappelle que dans ce cadre un
bureau de poste n'est pas forcément
rentable mais il est avant tout utile à
l'aune de la seule rentabilité
financière ce sont donc des milliers de
bureaux qui seront voués à la
disparition
à ce titre la présence postale dans les
territoires ruraux a déjà reculé depuis
plusieurs années les obligations de la
poste en terme d'aménagement du
territoire étant allégé par les lois
successives lé contrat de service public
qui prépare l'ouverture à la concurrence
un rapport de la commission européenne
au conseil soulignait déjà en 2006 que
je cite l'accès aux services postaux
dans les régions isolées risquait de
pâtir de la mise en oeuvre des
directives de libéralisation
il ne s'agit donc pas d'une inquiétude
nouvelle pour les élus et les citoyens
qui vous interpelle régulièrement sur
cette question j'ai moi même dans mon
département la meurthe et moselle était
sollicité par de nombreuses communes et
autres collectifs de défense qui ne
supporte plus la lente agonie de leurs
services postaux bien avant que la
réforme ne soit annoncée déjà tout était
mis en oeuvre pour tuer à petit feu les
agences locales dites non rentables et
inciter les usagers à se rendre dans des
centres plus important ainsi à en ville
et à les lire par exemple la réduction
de l'amplitude horaire d'ouverture des
bureaux se poursuit posant le problème
de l'accessibilité des usagers renvoyés
vers d'autres bureaux de poste allez
lire la prise d'activité des facteurs a
été transféré au centre voisin 20
kilomètres de leur tournée a envie
l'unique agent du guichet
n'est remplacé que de façon aléatoire
lors de ses absences
les usagers sont avertis le jour même
par un écriteau sur la porte de la
fermeture ou le cas échéant des horaires
du jour à cela la poste répond que les
clients peuvent désormais traiter la
plupart de leurs opérations sur internet
c'est oublier que souvent ce sont les
mêmes personnes qui sont aussi
confrontés à l'isolément à l'isolément
en termes de réseaux de
télécommunications je pense
particulièrement ici aux personnes âgées
comment ne pas s'émouvoir alors des
conclusions de la commission ailleret
qui souhaite que les surcoûts liés aux
missions de service public notamment en
terme d'aménagement du territoire
diminue pour arriver à l'équilibré
de quel équilibre parlons nous si l'état
continue sa participation capital
parallèlement il se désengage du
financement des missions de service
public
il doit ainsi 1 milliard à la poste au
titre des missions de service public
la priorité est donc le remboursement
des charges indues en outre le
changement de statut fait peser un
risque sur ses missions à savoir je les
rappelle l'accessibilité bancaire
la distribution de la presse le service
universel postal et l'aménagement du
territoire
vous nous direz que celles ci sont
confortés par la loi mais comment faire
sans financement l'article 2 bis affirme
vouloir gravé dans la loi la présence de
plus de 17000 points de contact mais de
quoi parlons nous depuis que le
processus de libéralisation et entamer
le nombre de bureaux de plein exercice a
chuté passant de 14 1947 bureau en 99 à
11400 22 fin 2008
parallèlement le nombre d' agence
postale communale n'a fait qu'augmenter
ainsi que celui des relais poste
or on ne fait pas les mêmes choses dans
un simple relais de poste ou dans un
bureau de plein exercice
quant aux agences postales elles sont le
résultat d'un chantage à la présence
postale
les collectivités qui font ce choix pour
leurs concitoyens supportent une charge
indue et mal compensés puisque l'aide
apportée atteint péniblement les 900
euros
ce que vous nommez donc publiquement
partenariat nous l'appelons
raquettes cette logique est assumé par
la direction de la poste qui estime que
la transformation de 500 bureaux de
postes par an en agence communale ou en
relais poste pourrait permettre de
ramener le surcoût généré par cette
mission d'aménagement du territoire à
260 millions en 2011
il s'agit donc bien de réduire la
présence postale
une telle logique fait craindre le pire
pour la mission de service public liés à
l'accessibilité bancaire qui n'est
assorti elle d'aucune obligation
territoriales pour remplir les
obligations en terme d'aménagement du
territoire
la loi dite régulation postale a
instauré un fonds de péréquation de la
présence postale au sujet duquel la
commission supérieure du service public
des postes et télécommunications a
regretté que ses modalités de
financement ne soient pas précisées et
dont les moyens restent à la fois
insuffisant et incertain en effet celui
ci est abondée par l'exonération sur la
taxe professionnelle
ça vous dit quelque chose taxe
professionnelle dont bénéficie la poste
à hauteur de 85% encore quelques
secondes même % maintenant grâce à la
commission du sénat alors que ces taxes
est appelée à disparaître dans la loi de
finances comment ce fonds sera t'il
alimenter demain mystère les directives
européennes n'interdisait pas de faire
supporter à l'ensemble des opérateurs
une obligation de desserte de l'ensemble
du territoire
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait jouer cette
obligation d'ailleurs les directive
n'oblige nullement a changé de statut
la définition des normes de qualité de
service et des règles d'accessibilité
des bureaux demeurent également une
prérogative nationale
nous ne voulons pas d'une telle
modernisation les exemples sont
aujourd'hui trop nombreux dans toute
l'europe qui croque prouve que
l'ouverture à la concurrence cumulé au
changement de statut se traduit par une
dégradation des services en suède
notamment on parle couramment de la
règle d un tiers la libéralisation
entraîner la suppression de un tiers du
personnel et de un tiers des bureaux de
poste ceci sans compter le fait que le
prix du timbre a augmenté de 40% pour
l'usager ait baissé de 30 % pour les
entreprises
voilà la modernisation de vous nous
proposez la logique est donc toujours la
même l'état se désengage
pour toutes ces raisons nous serons des
opposants déterminés à ce texte qui
sonne le glas des missions de service
public confiée à la poste mettant de
fait en péril la cohésion nationales et
le pacte républicain jeu
remercie de votre attention merci mes
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
madame bariza khiari pour le groupe
socialiste la parole monsieur collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur rapportèrent mes chers
collègues vous présenter ce projet de
loi dans un contexte particulier
l'inquiétude de la société française est
palpable
inquiétude face aux politiques de
libéralisation mené tambour battant par
votre gouvernement
inquiétude face à la précarité montante
inquiétudes lié au sentiment de
déclassement inquiétude pour l'avenir de
la nouvelle génération
inquiétude pour l'avenir du territoire
ce qui hier était assurée est
aujourd'hui susceptible d'être remise
aux brebis en cause à tout moment le
lien social se délite
on peut y voir l'émergence de
l'individualisme et le recul des
solidarités traditionnelles
pour ma part ce délitement cette
dissolution jeux olympiques au
libéralisme non tempéré que vous
appliquez à tous les pans de notre
économie
la généralisation la banalisation du
travail dominical fragilise les familles
le paquet fiscal contesté jusque dans
vos rangs privilégie les plus aisés
effet reporté la fiscalité sur les
ménages de classe moyenne parallèlement
à ces des red et régularise dérégulation
qui précarisent chaque jour davantage
nos concitoyens brouille les repères
dégradent leur vie quotidienne vous
mener une politique qui se résume à
l'affaiblissement des solidarités
collectives issus du programme du
conseil national de la résistance que
vous détricoter avec constance la cible
principale
c'est notre système de protection
sociale et le service public non
seulement le périmètre du service public
s'est réduit comme peau de chagrin
mais là où il est irremplaçable
indispensables comme la santé et
l'éducation
vous ne lui donnez plus les moyens
d'être un service de qualité pour
dissiper ce climat anxiogène
et occulter les vraies difficultés
sociales et économiques votre
gouvernement nous propose comme remède
un débat sur l'identité nationale le
tempo est choisi à dessein les français
l'ont bien compris
d'une part la manoeuvre de diversion
face à leurs programmes à leurs
problèmes quotidiens et notamment à la
dégradation l'emploi et d'autre part des
visées électoralistes qui ne trompe
personne
dans ce débat sur l'identité apparaîtra
sans doute que l' attachement au service
public notamment à la poste est une des
composantes forte de cette identité
le lien affectif des français avec la
poste et son personnel excède largement
ce rôle économique tant ce rôle social
est important
vous avez les yeux rivés sur un tableau
de bord vous contentant de mesures et
des performances financières
les coûts et les surcoûts sans vraiment
prendre la mesure de l'attachement de
nos concitoyens à leur poste
c'est pourquoi la votation citoyenne a
rencontré ainsi fort écho dans la
population
et là vous avez connu commis une erreur
d'appréciation puis une faute
votre erreur d'appréciation et de ne pas
avoir anticipé une telle mobilisation
votre faute celle de l'avoir discréditer
en l'assimilant à une mascarade en la
dénonçant comme une manipulation
comment comment un gouvernement issu
d'un mouvement dit populaire peut-il à
ce point méprisées une expression
populaire d'une telle ampleur dans un
ouvrage intitulé secteur de france on
s'aperçoit que les 100000 facteurs qui
sillonne la france 6 jours sur 7
contribuer à constituer un lien social
fort et que leur passage quotidien
représente un rythme important pour
nombre de nos concitoyens qu'on
l'intervenant ainsi il contribue à
incarner chaque jour l'égalité
républicaine et l'unité du territoire
tout comme les hussards noirs de la
république le postier et l'image de la
république
ce projet de loi aussi bien le titre un
consacré au changement de statut que les
titres 2
transcrivant la dernière directive
postale est une mesure est une menace
forte sur les missions de service public
détenu par la poste
le gouvernement nous assure qu'il n'est
pas question d'ouvrir à des actionnaires
privés le capital de la poste
les expériences récentes nous montrent
qu'un changement de statut et bien
l'antichambre de la privatisation
d'ailleurs un proche conseiller du
président de la république ne dit pas le
contraire
en parlant de la poste il a déclaré ce
matin qu'il n'y a pas de garantie
éternelle
contrairement à ce que vous dites en
évoquant le verrou du service du service
à caractère du service public à
caractère national
le financement des missions de service
public de la poste est compromis
notamment la mission de présence postale
même en tout portant à 100 % comme la
comme l'a proposé notre rapporteur
l'abattement de la taxe professionnelle
et la future cotisation complémentaire
le fonds de péréquation assurant la
présence postale demeurer sous alimentés
le titre 2-2 ce projet de loi en
entérinant la fin du secteur réservé
fragilise le principe de la péréquation
tarifaire instrument essentiel de
l'égalité républicaine
la création d'un fonds de compensation
abondé par les nouveaux entrants soit en
fonction du volume soit en fonction du
chiffre d'affaires n'y changera rien à
court terme
l'un des derniers services services
publics de proximité est voué à
disparaître de nos territoires les plus
fragiles c'est à dire des moins
rentables
mes collègues ont évoqué le rôle
essentiel de la présence postale dans
les zones rurales
pour ma part j'aimerais insister sur la
présence postale à paris et dans les
zones urbaines sensibles
en 98 déjà dans un rapport baptisé de
malades ville notre collègue jean pierre
sueur s'alarmer déjà alors que les 3 315
mille employés de la poste à l'époque
faisait qu'on comptait un employé
postale pour 180 habitants les habitants
des zones urbaines sensibles
prévoyez vous voyez se rassurent passé à
1 pour 670 40% des zones urbaines
sensibles ne comporter aucun bureau de
poste alors qu'elle
représenter une population de plus de 4
millions de personnes
les chiffres sont si sont-ils différents
aujourd'hui on compte aujourd'hui un
bureau de poste pour 15000 habitants
seine-saint-denis c'est catastrophique
les effectifs sont également faibles ce
qui explique que le moindre incident
vient perturber l'ensemble du trafic
on relève ainsi que les non
remplacements de personnel absent se
traduisent par une ou plusieurs journées
sans distribution danse dans certains
secteurs de la première couronne
n'oublions pas que la première couronne
comporte pourtant un nombre
d'entreprises extrêmement important qui
participe à la vitalité économique de
l'île de france
certains courriers considéré comme non
prioritaire sont distribués de manière
aléatoire et différée à cela s'ajoutent
les temps d'attentes de plus en plus
important au guichet alors que les
quartiers sensibles souffre déjà d'un
certain nombre de malaises économiques
et sociaux d'une relégation
par rapport à d'autres territoires de la
république va-t-on de surcroît leur
imposer un recul supplémentaire en
limitant leur accès aux services de la
poste
car telle est bien la question en
prenant le schéma d'une limitation
progressive de l'implication de l'époque
de l'état dans l'entreprise poste on se
prive d'un outil fondamental est
nécessaire pour r d pour aider certains
territoires
on renonce à vouloir reconquérir les
territoires dits perdus de la république
la convention signée en 97 entre l'anru
la poste déclaré pourtant la poste a un
rôle vis-à-vis des zones urbaines
sensibles en améliorant l'accessibilité
des services postaux aux populations de
ces quartiers en favorisant une desserte
de qualité un travail de proximité
lorsque des logiques de rentabilité
seront au coeur du fonctionnement de
l'entreprise
comment pourra-t-on envisager des
politiques d'aménagement du territoire
qui soit vraiment efficace
cela aura-t-il un sens ne nous privons
pas d'un instrument efficace pour aller
vers ces quartiers parce que le service
public est consubstantiel de notre
modèle social modèles auxquels nous
sommes attachés
parce qu'il est d'une part porteur de
valeurs de solidarité et d'autres pas
l'amortisseur social en temps de crise
pour les plus d'efforts et défavorisées
il vous faut conclure dans quelques
secondes j'ai conclu monsieur le
président le groupe socialiste
s'opposera résolument à ce projet mais
si ma chère collègue
la parole est maintenant monsieur
christophe andré frassa pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
chez le président chez le ministre
chers collègues le projet de loi dont
nous entamons depuis hier la discussion
a déjà fait couler beaucoup d'encre et a
déjà fait l'objet d'un travail de sape
constant de la part de certains
syndicats et partis politiques
d'opposition au regard des enjeux
auxquels la poste devra faire face à
compter du 1er janvier 2011
il faut dead il faudrait être aveugle et
par je ne sais quel dogme ou tout
simplement inconscient pour ne pas
comprendre qu'il faille lui faire
bénéficier d'une plus grande liberté de
manoeuvre
aussi je tiens à vous remercier monsieur
le ministre pour votre implication
personnelle dans cette réforme et pour
avoir voulu que le débat parlementaire
soit abordée dans la manière la plus
ouverte possible pour cela je tiens à
vous renouveler tout mon soutien pour
faire aboutir cette nécessaire réforme
de la poste afin de garantir sa
compétitivité face aux nouveaux défis
la lecture du compte rendu de l'audition
de christian escrocs estrosi devant la
commission de l'économie
je souhaiterais appelez votre attention
sur deux problématiques figurant dans le
projet de loi à savoir d'une part la
détention du capital de la poste et
d'autre part le rôle de l'autorité de
régulation des communications
électroniques et des postes
l'afutt le premier du projet de loi fait
évoluer le statut juridique de la poste
en transformant à compter du 1er janvier
2010 en société anonyme
suivant la volonté exprimée par le
président de la république en décembre
2008 le gouvernement s'était engagé à ce
que le capital de la poste soit il reste
détenu à 100% par l'état ou par des
pairs d'autres personnes morales
appartenant au secteur public
je me félicite que les débats de la
commission d'économies sur la rédaction
de l'article 1er
est améliorée de manière conséquente sa
finalité et je tiens ici à saluer
l'initiative notre rapporteur pierre
hérisson qui a souhaité que le capital
soit détenu à hauteur de 100% par l'état
et par d'autres personnes morales
appartenant au secteur public
cependant de nombreuses voix se sont
élevées pour réclamer que le capital de
la poste soit détenu par l'état et la
cdc plutôt que d'autres acteurs
institutionnels publics dont les
intérêts pourrait fluctuer en fonction
des desiderata des actionnaires privés
de ces opérateurs souhaitant donc aller
plus loin l'amendement que je
présenterai permettra de garantir en
plus de l'état que seules des
institutions financières publiques
françaises qui exercent des activités
d'intérêt général pour le compte de
l'état pourront entrer au capital de la
poste
à ce jour et à ma connaissance seul la
caisse des dépôts et consignations
répondent à ces critères
cela permettrait je crois de ne pas
fermer les ports du capital de la poste
à des institutions similaires la cdc
tout en restant vigilants quant à ce
qu'ils souhaiteraient ayant trait à
l'avenir
répondant à mon courrier à ce sujet
christian estrosi m'a écrit je cite
qu'il partageait mes observations sur le
fait que seul l'état et la caisse des
dépôts doivent pouvoir détenir le
capital de la poste
nous aurons donc l'occasion d'en
reparler lors de la discussion des
articles
le titre ii du projet de loi élargit les
missions de l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes et définit les obligations de la
poste vis-à-vis de celle-ci selon la
lecture que l'on pourrait faire des
articles du titre 2 l'autorité de
régulation semblerait d'imposer des
contraintes qu à la seule poste sans que
cela concerne les futurs concurrents de
cette dernière même s'il est évident à
mes yeux que les futurs prestataires
titulaire de l'autorisation prévue à
l'article l 3 du code des postes et
communications électroniques seront
soumis aux mêmes obligations que celles
mentionnées à l'article 20 du projet de
loi
j'estime nécessaire que le gouvernement
le précise noir sur blanc afin de
dissiper tout doute sur ce point
dans un contexte où sur un sujet de
cette importance l'opinion publique a
été abreuvés quotidiennement de contre
vérités cela éviterait de faire accroire
un traitement différencié entre la poste
et ses futurs concurrents
aussi je vous serais très reconnaissant
de bien vouloir me confirmer que la
poste et l'ensemble des opérateurs qui
officieront sur le territoire national
seront traités sur un même pied
d'égalité par l'autorité de régulation
enfin monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement s'est engagé à maintenir et
préserver la présence de la poste sur
l'ensemble du territoire que ce soit en
zone rurale et de montagne
ainsi que sur les territoires les plus
éloignés votre projet de loi garantit
pour la première fois choses qui ne
l'étaient pas précédemment
les quatre missions de la poste ainsi
les critères actuels d'accessibilité au
réseau des points de contact au titre du
service universel seront maintenus et
les articles 2 et 3 consacré à sur la
mission d'aménagement du territoire de
la poste
ce dont je me réjouis vous avez même
proposé d'aller au delà en prenant des
engagements en matière de maintien du
périmètre de la mission d'aménagement du
territoire ou de pérennité de son
financement
partout où elles sont présentes les
agences postales communales et les
points relais commerçant compensent en
partie les carences et remplissent
particulièrement bien le rôle leurs
premiers résultats sont d'ailleurs
significatif
vous avez marqué votre volonté de
poursuivre leur développement et je m'en
félicite
cependant comme l'a si bien souligné mon
collègue jacques blanc il serait
judicieux de réfléchir dès aujourd'hui à
la possibilité de mutualiser les
services publics et d'étendre les
missions purement postale de ses bureaux
et retiré
il me paraît nécessaire de sortir du
schéma classique où seule la poste et
les collectivités territoriales auraient
leur mot à dire
schéma qui conduit inéluctablement à ne
raisonner qu'en termes de coût financier
avec une poste qui se désengage de ses
bureaux non rentables et des
collectivités territoriales qui refusent
d'accroître leurs charges et la
fiscalité locale offrir sous un même
toit une gamme élargie de services
débordant largement de ceux
traditionnellement offerts par la poste
et répondant soit des activités reconnu
socialement nécessaire soit à des
services d'intérêt général indispensable
aux besoins de nos concitoyens pour être
une solution
ses points d'accueil pourrait assurer la
prestation des services publics
aujourd'hui absents ou disparus il
pourrait offrir par ailleurs toute forme
de conseil expertise et services dans
des domaines aussi variés que l'aide à
la personne
la garde d'enfant ou services domicile
ils pourraient enfin aider à la création
d'emplois et l'insertion professionnelle
durable
même si cette réflexion sort un tout
petit peu des débats que nous engageons
aujourd'hui vous comprendrez monsieur le
ministre que nous ne pourrons aider la
poste à se développer face à ses
concurrents sans réfléchir à l'évolution
de ses points d'accueil dans les zones
les plus retirés de notre pays et ce
dans le cadre de sa mission de service
public auquel tous nos compatriotes sont
très attachés je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant madame annie
david pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen sénateurs des
parties gauche pour 4 minutes
vous avez la parole mes chers collègues
même sur vous monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
on ne le sait que trop toute réforme
structurelle d'une entreprise
s'accompagne de casse tant sociales que
des conditions de travail
aussi je souhaite vous faire part des
craintes importante des personnels sur
votre réforme la poste aujourd'hui tous
métiers confondus c'est 281 7000
salariés dont 142 mille fonctionnaires
145 1000 salariés de droit privé 10
contractuels soient en cdi soit en cdd
c'est aussi plus de 200 filiales en
france et à l'étranger
on constate la diversité de structures
et de situation des salariés regroupés
en de nombreux métiers parfois très
différents mais tous complémentaires
pour accomplir leur mission de service
public
résultat de l'histoire cette diversité
est aussi la conséquence de choix
délibéré et constant des pouvoirs
publics et des dirigeants de la poste
d'aller à marche forcée vers une société
commerciale filialiser déconstruire et /
activités c'est finalement classique
monsieur le ministre c'est diviser pour
mieux réformer une des conséquences de
la transformation des ptt en france
télécom et la poste fait le choix donner
aux salariés d'être reclassifier ou
reclassés traduisez par demeurer
fonctionnaires ou intégrer la nouvelle
structure et devenir un contractuel
soumis au droit privé a ainsi été créé
une catégorie de salariés que l'on
pourrait nommer les ni ni ni tout à fait
des salariés de droit privé car ils n'en
n'ont pas tous les droits
ni plus tout à fait des fonctionnaires
après des années de lutte
elles et ils sont toujours dans une
situation de discrimination dans le
rapport larcher d'ailleurs monsieur le
président en 2002 en souligné
déjà le caractère anormal ainsi qu
existe aujourd'hui une multitude de
situations salariales et régime
juridique hétérogènes et inégalitaire un
ornithorynque juridique selon les dires
mêmes des personnels cette superposition
de régime laisse perdurer de nombreuses
zones de non droit après un moins disant
salarial et une aggravation des
conditions de travail
votre énième réforme si elle était
adoptée représenterait en outre un
nivellement par le bas des retraites car
cela entraînerait pour ses salariés un
passage de l'ircantec vers l'agirc
entraînant une augmentation des
cotisations et une baisse des retraites
de même l'ircantec n'y survivrait pas à
terme alerté sur cette question le
ministre estrosi s'est engagé en
commission à trouver une solution qui
satisfasse toutes les parties
sachez que nous serons très vigilants
quant aux suites données sur ce dossier
primordial
il en est de même de la proposition
d'actions gratuites en direction des
salariés d'une part seuls les cadres
pourraient y prétendre donc nous ne
pouvons y souscrire d'autant qu'un tel
dispositif associé à celui des primes
autre proposition de ce projet que nous
contestons favorise une pac une
politique de bas salaires
d'autre part cette option n'étant
valable que deux ans cela aboutira à
terme à des reventes de la part des
salariés avec les risques d'une
privatisation indirect est rampante et
vous voudriez nous faire croire que
jamais la poste ne sera privatisée avec
cette réforme la poste deviendrait une
société anonyme comme france télécom
issues toutes deux des ptt et l'on ne
peut s'empêcher de regarder leurs
destins parallèles ainsi à france
télécom nous sommes face à de
dramatiques situation humaine et il faut
savoir qu'à la poste il y a déjà
énormément de salariés qui souffrent de
cette gestion du personnel pathogènes
nous ne prenons pas le statu quo en
refusant le passage de la poste en une
société anonyme
au contraire nous appelons de nos voeux
une réforme d'envergure qui se
traduirait pour les usagers par la
pérennisation d'un véritable service
public de la poste et pour les salades
par l'acquisition d'un statut juridique
unifié notamment grâce à la convention
collective unique comportant des droits
pour toutes et tous au moins équivalents
à ceux contenus dans le code du travail
pour conclure à l'heure où l'on commence
à mesurer l'étendue et la gravité de la
souffrance au travail la mission
parlementaire de notre commission des
affaires sociales sur le mal être au
travail en témoigne à l'heure où
certaines entreprises commencent à
revenir en arrière et où l'actualité
nous rappelle chaque jour les dégâts
humains que l'ultralibéralisme engendre
cette réforme est déjà dépassé et ce
n'est n'est plus en phase avec les
besoins des populations en ce début de
21e siècle
voilà pourquoi nous voterons contre la
transformation de la poste en hesse a
justifié par aucune nécessité économique
structurelle salariale si ce n'est celle
d'une future privatisation de la poste
merci ma chère collègue la parole est
maintenant notre collègue roland
courteau
pour le groupe socialiste et pour huit
minutes
la parole non chers collègues merci
monsieur le président un féminisme se
rapporte à monsieur le président de la
commission mais chers collègues
une première remarque si vous le voulez
bien ce sont bien les gouvernements de
droite qui ont conduit la négociation de
la troisième directive postale
on est d'accord c'est bien le ministre
françois lens qui avait averti que si la
france estimé suffisantes les garanties
concernant le financement du service
universel
elle demanderait le maintien du secteur
réservé en est d'accord
cependant la proposition de directive
n'a pas été fondamentalement modifiée et
pourtant la phrase n'a rien demandé et a
approuvé le texte européen et seuls les
eurodéputés de gauche s'y sont opposés
et pour une bonne raison
en fait tout le discours ultra libérale
de la commission européenne se
retrouvent dans cette directive que le
gouvernement a avalisé
deuxième remarque fraîchement monsieur
le ministre à qui voulez vous faire
croire que pour affronter la concurrence
et se moderniser la poste est dans
l'obligation de changer de statut
tout le monde est persuadé qui a
véritablement la anguille sous roche et
que la transformation en société anonyme
constitue le premier pas vers la
privatisation
mais oui le précédent gdf rod encore ici
au dessus de nos têtes
nul n'a oublié dans le pays que les
ministres nicolas sarkozy avait promis
urbi et orbi de ne pas privatiser gaz de
france d'ailleurs instruits
par ce précédent et quelques autres les
français peuvent vous écrire la suite de
l'histoire de la poste
si celles ci deviennent domaine société
anonyme
surtout après les propos du conseiller
de l'elysée ce matin même ainsi 1 1
les piliers du service public à la
française tombé au champ d'honneur
ainsi et quoi que vous nous disiez vous
avez choisi de vous attaquer à l'un des
seuls symboles du service public encore
debout et ce ne sont pas les forums pas
que vous faites mine dirigée contre la
dérive de privatisations ainsi engagé
qui rassureront les français c'est
testons s'est largement exprimée par
rapport à cette digue de papier que
pourrait être l'amendement faisant de la
poste un service public national
en vérité le sort de l'entreprise a été
décidé est ficelé depuis longtemps le
gouvernement a pioché dans le rapport et
y aurait l'habillage du moment vous
préparé ce qui a toujours été envisagée
par la droite
la privatisation future de la poste
c'est votre choix assumé le inutile
d'invoquer l'europe où des questions de
technique de financement
en fait ce changement de statut et
surtout dogmatique et vous avez décidé
d'engager une bataille idéologique
contre les services publics
alors vous nous trouverez face à vous
car notre volonté est de garantir et de
sauvegarder une entreprise publique dont
l'utilité sociale économique et recoller
de tous et ce choix là nous nous
l'assumons notez bien que c'est cette
même volonté qui s'est affirmée lors de
la votation citoyenne une votation que
certains ici on tenter de disqualifier
je rappelle que cette forme de
référendum fut inspiré par celui mis en
oeuvre par la ligue des droits de
l'homme et qu'il fallait être majeur
présent physiquement et signer une
ce d'émargement dans l'aude par exemple
45 mille votants sur une population de
300 mille habitants se sont déplacés
pour montrer leur attachement à la poste
à ceux qui doutent à ceux qui dénigrent
ici je leur dis que les listes
d'émargement sont disponibles et à leur
disposition et m'ont collé le master et
non ne me démentira pas une votation que
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ont
voulu ignorer ou qu'ils ont même des
beignets et c'est cette même volonté
mesdames et messieurs qui se serait
affirmé très largement si le
gouvernement avait accepté d'organiser
un référendum
et oui et oui l'attachement des français
à la poste très fort car la poste n'est
pas une entreprise comme une autre
la poste c'est bien plus qu'un réseau de
transport et de distribution
c'est un vecteur de lien social de
développement économique et
d'aménagement du territoire
c'est le symbole du service public à la
française
c'est le symbole de l'égalité
républicaine
admettez monsieur le ministre mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité que les
sociétés de l'avenir ne saurait être
vous est totalement à la performance et
à la réussite financière
admettez comme d'autres l'ont décrit que
la solidarité et le dévouement au bien
commun
ainsi qu'une organisation fondée sur
l'intérêt collectif
c'est à dire le service public puisse
équilibrer la toute-puissante logique de
la rentabilité
monsieur le ministre votre projet est
néfaste pour le service postal et pour
les personnels
vous vous persistez à refuser un
référendum nous nous persistons à
considérer que le peuple a son mot à
dire car la poste c'est la propriété des
français
pourquoi refusez vous de consulter les
français sur un projet dont les enjeux
sont particulièrement lourd par rapport
au lien social dans les zones rurales
comme dans les quartiers populaires et
par rapport à l'aménagement du
territoire
auriez vous peur du résultat si plutôt
que d'ignorer ou de des beignets la
votation citoyenne du 3 octobre le
gouvernement avait pris la peine de
prendre en considération cette
mobilisation
il aurait pu constater que l'attachement
des français au service public de la
poste déborder largement les frontières
partisanes
sachez le des citoyens de gauche comme
de droite sont venus exprimer
cet attachement à ce service public de
toute manière
tôt ou tard vous n'échapperez pas au
référendum d'initiative populaire car il
faudra bien qu'un jour ou l'autre soit
inscrit à l'ordre du jour des travaux du
parlement le projet de loi organique
relatif à cette disposition
constitutionnelle
et là vous verrez ce que pensent
réellement le peuple
oui votre projet est néfaste pour le
service public
oui nous nous considérons que le statut
public de l'entreprise constitue une
garantie nécessaire dans le domaine de
la préservation des missions de service
public ou du contrôle de la stratégie du
groupe et que le statut d'exploitant
autonome public nous paraît tout à fait
adapté à la modernisation de la poste
hélas son développement oui nos craintes
allaient le changement de statut de la
poste sont particulièrement fortes
non nous ne voulons pas que la poste
devienne un vestige de notre modèle
social
par ailleurs le projet de loi les 40
secondes de jarny pas un financement
suffisant et pérenne des missions de
service public ni le fonds de
compensation du service universel postal
ni le fonds national de péréquation
postale territoriale
même après les modifications de la
commission ne dispose de ressources
suffisantes et pérenne dans un contexte
de réforme de la fiscalité locale
nous proposons donc des amendements sur
cette question majeure à nos yeux car en
l'absence d'un financement intégral à la
poste
accenture à la recherche de diminution
de ses coûts suppressions d'emplois
réduction de la présence postale remise
en cause de la distribution du courrier
jours sur sept et à j + m en conclusion
je dirais que pour que la post
poursuivre son développement et sa
modernisation
elle doit aussi pouvoir s'appuyer sur
l'ensemble de son personnel et pour cela
la poste doit disposer d'un pacte social
ambitieux afin de préserver l'emploi et
assurer de bonnes garanties sociales aux
postiers j'ai récemment reçu des
courriers où il était écrit je cite il
vous appartient vous conclut mme de
choisir entre l' aventure et le bon sens
entre l'intérêt général et une
orientation mercantile
fin de citation eh bien monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez compris mon choix
qui est celui aussi du groupe socialiste
effet c'est celui du bon sens et de
l'intérêt général
et voilà pourquoi nous nous opposerons à
votre projet merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue alain fouché pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire salue
alain laroche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je rappelle
moi aussi que la poste occupe une place
centrale dans la vie quotidienne de
dizaines de millions de français aussi
bien par les missions qu'elle assume
partout sur le territoire que par la
mission sociale forte et elle et c'est
important de le dire
le premier employeur après l'état ces
dernières décennies
la poste a su évoluer et s'adapter aux
mutations de l'économie et de la société
il est vrai que ces derniers mois nous
avons su avec des textes qui était
proposée par la majorité soutenir le
projet de banque postale et dans ce
projet il était bien convenu que la
poste devait rester implanté au maximum
sur les territoires la banque postale
est une réussite totale
parce que ses dirigeants ont su gérer
sans s'aventurer
contrairement à ce qu'ont fait d'autres
groupes
pourtant la poste aujourd'hui est
confronté à un bouleversement majeur de
son environnement qui pourrait rendre
son avenir incertain en particulier
l'insuffisance de ses fonds propres
n'empêche de procéder aux
investissements nécessaires pour
affronter ses concurrents les plus
directs
or son statut actuel chacun n'a pas la
même vision d'établissements publics ne
l'autorisent pas accéder à des sources
de financement élargi pour y remédier
une modification de sa forme juridique
est aujourd'hui nécessaire
tel est le sens du projet de loi qui
nous est soumis pour insister sur deux
points auxquels le gouvernement aussi
s'est engagée qui me paraissent
essentiels c'est la présence
territoriale
tout le monde est concerné tout le monde
le souhaite et là est le deuxième point
tout le monde souhaite aussi sur le
maintien du caractère entièrement public
de l'entreprise
notre commission des affaires
économiques à l'initiative de son
rapporteur pierre hérisson et d'autres
sénateurs outils et pierre hérisson fait
un travail remarquable dans le domaine
de la poste depuis des années a tenu à
ce que nous apportions des garanties
pour répondre aux inquiétudes
manifestées sur le maintien des 17000
points de présence postale ainsi at-elle
décidé que le nombre de points de
contact de l'opérateur sur le territoire
national ne pourra être inférieur à
17000 disposition qui mérite
naturellement d'être pleinement approuvé
et le gouvernement monsieur mines et
s'est engagé à son tour sur ce point la
poste prendra aussi la forme juridique
d'une société anonyme tout en demeurant
une entreprise publique
les ministres ont être le ministre était
très précis hier le texte
kress simplement le cadre juridique qui
permet au groupe la poste de recevoir
une augmentation de capital
par une souscription de l'état ou
d'établissements publics dépendant
directement de l'état
la poste a besoin d'un minimum de 2
milliards 700 millions pour arriver au
même niveau de compétence et de
compétitivité que les autres postes
européennes
cet apport sera exclusivement le fait de
l'état ou d'entreprises publiques pas un
seul euro ne devra provenir du secteur
privé notre commission ayant précisé
qu'en dehors de l'état seules les
personnes morales de droit public
pourrait détenir une part de son capital
enfin la transformation en société
anonyme ne changera en rien la situation
des personnels fonctionnaires et
contractuels les fonctionnaires
conservant leur statut les garanties
d'emploi et de retraite qui sont
associés et sous réserve des garanties
qui vont être apportées au cours de nos
débats concernant le régime de retraite
des agents de droit privé actuellement
employées par la poste au fur à mesure
des jours les jours de réflexion sur ce
texte
les réunions de la commission le projet
évolue dans des conditions plus
satisfaisante et plus sécuritaire pour
nos populations et nos territoires et ce
projet répond aujourd'hui à nos
préoccupations à celle des territoires
et celle des habitants mais nous serons
aussi défendre son projet sur le
territoire et nous serons nous faire
comprendre par les populations qu'ils
savent que nous voterons un contexte
merci beaucoup merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à monsieur jean
desessard
pour attacher au groupe socialiste qui
une fois l'effet de surprise passé à 8
minutes
voilà vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue pour lui minutes sur
président monsieur le ministre shah
collègue monsieur le président est-ce
qu'il ya encore quelque chose à ajouter
après les excellentes interventions de
mes collègues socialistes communistes
radicaux de gauche excellente éminente
interventions mais une sainte
interrogations sur votre présence à ce
débat monsieur le ministre je ne parle
pas du ministre ici présentes mais du
ministre qui est absent le ministre de
l'industrie
je pense qu'il aurait été plus
symbolique plutôt que de faire traiter
ce sujet par le ministre de l'industrie
pour montrer que la poste n'est pas une
entreprise comme hinault de le faire
traiter par monsieur eric woerth
ministre du budget aurait pu le palais
de l'investissement de l'état ministre
des comptes publics qui auraient pu nous
parler du suivi de la caisse de dépôt
ministre de la fonction publique qui
aurait pu nous parler de la mission de
service public de la poste ministre de
la réforme de l'état pour la
modernisation nécessaire de cet
établissement public vous donner un
mauvais signe en donnant ce projet de
loi en faisant traiter ce projet de loi
par le ministre de l'industrie
une seconde remarque sur le second volet
qui concerne la libéralisation ou un
terme plus académique
la transposition de la troisième
directive européenne concernant le
secteur postal
l'argument souvent repris ici et qu'il
faut s'adapter à la législation
européenne et qu'il faut donc en
conséquence soumettre le secteur postal
à la concurrence et qu'il faut
libéraliser le marché
certes mais pour un peu on vous entendre
est exprimé des regrets d'aboutir à
cette situation
messi est alors qui a voté cette
directive européenne
si douloureuse appliquée pas les genres
député verts yve s'y sont opposés bien
sûr ce sont les eurodéputés ump
est ce une erreur de manipulation des
boutons de vote de tout un band
eurodéputés à l'instar du député jean
françois lamour qu'on l'on avait connu
plus habiles dans la maîtrise des
touches bien sûr que non puisque cette
directive a aussi reçu l'aval des
ministres du goût de votre gouvernement
dont l'ump au niveau européen est pour
la libéralisation du marché postal
l'ouverture à la concurrence et l'on
voudrait nous faire croire qu'il ya une
coupure totale entre les parlementaires
ump de bruxelles et les parlementaires
ump du palais du luxembourg
cela ferait désordre pour un parti aux
commandes qui joue un rôle important au
niveau européen et dont le chef
incontesté se targue de moraliser le
capitalisme est de supprimer l'ensemble
des paradis fiscaux de la planète
alors soyons sérieux et considérons que
la ligne politique et biologique de
l'ump est l'ouverture de la concurrence
du secteur postal
oui mais voilà ce n'est pas aussi simple
de la mettre en oeuvre dans notre pays
si attachés au service public à la
française
car le gouvernement craint la
mobilisation de salariés de la poste
le rejet de la réforme par le bénis par
l'opinion attaché aux voitures jaunes
aux oiseaux enfin tout ce qui est un
signe dans les campagnes cela a été
confirmé le 3 octobre à la participation
de plus de deux millions de personnes à
votation citoyenne
il craint également la rebellion d'élus
ruraux
soucieux de la présence de service
public sur l'ensemble du territoire
si si mes chers collègues cela existe la
résistance de l'ump à certaines réformes
et le rejet du projet de loi par le
conseil constitutionnel je fais
référence au neuvième alinéa du
préambule de la constitution de 46 c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement
avance masqué pour étouffer les
résistances vous clamez avec des indes
et des accents de sincérité la main sur
le coeur que vous souhaitez que la poste
reste une entreprise publique qu'il ne
s'agit en aucun cas de privatiser et
même de la rendre un privatisable je ne
reviendrai pas sur les précédents
pourtant la démarche est connu à
habituel d'administration publique
on devient établissement public
d'établissements publics
on devient et sa à capitaux à 100 % des
sacs capitaux à 100% on devient à 51% de
capitaux publics pour garder la majorité
et puis ensuite on veut garder la
majorité à 34% et on finit par une et ça
tout court à 26 % pour france télécom je
prendrai jeu prendrait acte de votre
principal argument pour défendre le
changement de statut non pas l'argument
non dits non avoués qui motive le patron
de la poste
celui qui a été l'initiateur de ce
changement de statut
je ne parle pas de la vente âge qu'il va
retirer au niveau des rémunérations
celui de multiplier par 2 par 3 voire
plus le montant des revenus des cadres
dirigeants mais si mais si monsieur
rapporteur vous savez bien que dans ce
cercle dirigeant et joue à ceux qui vont
avoir la plus grosse rémunération bien
sûr
non pas l'argument non dits non avoués
qui motive le dirigeant multipliant les
acquisitions les cessions les fusions
les liquidations
bref le statut de société anonyme
autorise jeu favori des dirigeants
prédateurs le monopoly boursiers
l'argument officiel est le besoin de
financement d'un montant évalué à près
de 2,7 milliards pour moderniser la
poste comme les règles européennes au
nom du respect de la libre concurrence
ne permettent pas à l'état cet
investissement il faut donc donc doté la
poste d'un statut de société anonyme
pour que la caisse des dépôts et l'état
investisse cette forme cette somme sous
forme de capital vous pensez que la
commission européenne sur monsieur lozès
un égout reste une grosse minute
je vous dirais bien que j'engage la
conclusion d'un jet mois mais ne vous en
faites pas je suis là toute la semaine
ce que je vais pas dire maintenant vous
aurez l'occasion de l'entendre
à moins que vous ne soyez pas là toute
la semaine mais bon alors vous pensez
que la commission européenne va être
dupe de cette grosse ficelle
ainsi elle est un établissement
financier vont contribuer à hauteur de
2,7 milliards sans hésite sans exiger un
retour sur investissement et cela
passerait inaperçu auprès de la
concurrence et de la commission
européenne
autant dire tout de suite vous lancez la
privatisation et en plus vous lui donnez
un cadeau de 2,7 milliards voilà alors
je vais m'engager vers la conclusion
après une remarque à monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit hier lors de la présentation du
projet de loi craindre
achevée messieurs le présent jeu il faut
décompter le temps de wimbée lime
interrompre un monsieur le ministre vous
avez dit hier lors de la présentation du
projet de loi craindre au mieux vous ai
même dit que l'opposition ne vous
pourrissent la semaine eh bien monsieur
ce risque de vous pourrir la semaine
je le prends car je considère que ce
projet de loi va pourrir la vie de
milliers de salariés d'un million
d'usagers pour des années et des années
allait bien finir monsieur le président
allez vous concluez vous concluez aller
c'est pourquoi les sénatrices et les
sénateurs verts à l'instar de l'ensemble
de l'opposition s'opposeront à ce texte
considère qu'il doit être mis en débat
dans la société et qu'il doit être
soumis à un référendum national
merci
la discussion générale et claude venu
demander au gouvernement
simplement je voudrais pour que pendant
que nous y sommes
la discussion de la motion référendaire
pour que chacun le note bien aura lieu
demain matin à 9h30
l'auteur au nom des auteurs en
occurrence le président bayle aura 20
minutes puis la commission monsieur le
président et maureen monsieur le
rapporteur éric 120 minutes et le
gouvernement
un temps estimé maximum de 20 minutes
naturellement le gouvernement s'exprime
quand il l'entend
le temps attribué au groupe en
supplément de ce temps et pour l'ump de
39 minutes
le groupe socialiste de 32 minutes le
groupe de l'union centriste de 16
minutes
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
sénateurs des partis de gauche de 15
minutes
le groupe du rdse de 13 minutes et les
sénateur n'appartenant à aucun groupe de
cinq minutes je voudrais préciser avant
la réponse des ministres le déroulement
approximatif de notre journée que chacun
est bien en tête après la réponse du
ministre nous avons examiné trois
motions puis à l'issue de ces motions
entameront l'examen du texte avec 27
amendements à l'article 1er puis 12
orateurs inscrits sur l'article 1er est
ainsi ira le déroulement pour une séance
ce soir qui devra s'achever autour de
minuit pour permettre à 9h30 de pouvoir
entamer l'examen de la motion
référendaire
j'ai obtenu l'accord des groupes ceux ci
bien confirmé acte est donnée de cette
organisation ce qui permet donc à chacun
de ramasser ses papiers jaunes d'autres
et de considérer que nous sommes
maintenant entrés
alors pour répondre monsieur michel
mercier répond d'abord un ensemble d
orateur si vous voulez bien venir ici et
ensuite monsieur estrosi sur le ministre
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
et c'est vrai que les français aiment la
poste et que nous aimons tous la poste
exactement
exactement et monsieur fisher vous ne
pouvez pas douter de cet amour que nous
avons tous pour la poste pour des
raisons tout simple et bien justement
madame borvo madame barbe aussi voulait
bien me laisser parler
ce sera vraiment nouveau de votre part
mais je voudrais dire que des preuves
je vais vous en donner et je vous
remercie de m'avoir poussé à entrer dans
le vif du sujet immédiatement je
voudrais aborder les questions qui sont
relatives à l'aménagement du territoire
et répondra ainsi aux dix sept sénateurs
et sénatrices qui sont intervenus et
tous ont abordé ce sujet de la présence
postale
monsieur estrosi répondra à chacun
d'entre vous sur les autres aspects du
texte mais je voudrais dire que tout
d'abord si nous sommes aussi attaché à
la poste comme service public et symbole
de saïx public c'est parce qu'il y a en
france
dix sept mille points de contact poste
nous sommes le seul pays européen à
avoir autant de points contacts poste
par habitant sauf peut-être avec le
portugal c'est cette présence
ce maillage de l'ensemble du territoire
qui fait l'originalité de la poste pour
le gouvernement est la poste le symbole
du service public de sa son organisation
de sa capacité à s'adapter et de sa
présence sur l'ensemble du territoire
dans le projet de loi qui vous est
soumis un certain nombre de garanties
sont apportées soit par le projet lui
même soit par les amendements qui ont
été déposés et discutés en commission et
acceptés par le gouvernement
tout d'abord le projet de loi rappelle
les missions de service public exercée
par la poste le service universel postal
le service du transport et de la
distribution de la presse
le service de la présence postale et de
services de l'accessibilité bancaire
ces quatre missions sont essentiels
elles sont différentes les unes des
autres et dans la perception que nos
citoyens
elles sont un ensemble et que l'on ne
peut pas partager que dans une commune
rurale ou dans le plus petit des hameaux
le facteur puissent venir chaque jour à
porter le courrier et le journal c'est
quelque chose qui fait qui est à la base
même de notre vie sociale que l'on
puisse trouver à moins de 5 km ou à
moins de 20 minutes en voiture un bureau
de contact poste est tout aussi
essentiel est qu'il y ait une banque
postale où tout le monde puisse ouvrir
un compte donne une autre perception de
la banque que celle que l'on a pu avoir
à travers la crise financière et je
crois que c'est très bien ainsi
le projet de loi tient compte à la fois
de cet attachement aux missions de
service public de la poste est aussi
tient compte
très naturellement des évolutions et des
choses la dématérialisation du courrier
le courrier électronique qui remplace le
croyait papier il serait vain par
exemple de vouloir maintenir partout des
bureaux de poste et de ne pas offrir aux
zones rurales l'accès au très haut débit
ce serait le contraire de ce qu'il faut
faire il faut maintenir la présence
postale sous un mode adapté et en même
temps offrir le très haut débit à tous
les territoires de notre pays et c'est
ce que le gouvernement
un souhaite faire alors des missions
d'aménagement du territoire 14001
communes ont un point poste sur leur
territoire quatorze mille communes sur
36 mille communes
c'est quand même une présence qui est
inimaginable
il suffit de voir les choses 60 % du
réseau de la poste est situé dans des
communes de moins de 2000 habitants ce
qui est quand même tout à fait
remarquable de cette présence postale à
laquelle nous sommes tous attachés
le projet de loi maintient ses quatre
missions
rien n'obligeait le gouvernement a
rappelé ses missions de service public
dans le texte
le texte avait une obligation
constitutionnelle d'un transcription
d'un directive est le gouvernement a
choisi de rappeler ses missions qui
étaient déjà inscrites dans la loi de
les rappeler de les ancrer à nouveau
dans le marbre législatif et de leur
donner un certain nombre de garanties
supplémentaires
on voit que vous avez une relation
lointaine avec lapierre mon cher
collègue parce que c'est assez rare que
marc le marbre secondes et quels sont
ces garanties supplémentaires que l'on
va inscrire dans le texte de loi
grâce au travail du rapporteur et de
l'ensemble de la commission
c'est tout d'abord inscrire dans la loi
il y aura pas moins de quatorze mille
points de contact poste ça c'est très
important pour la première fois figurera
dans un texte législatif
le nombre des dix sept mille points
c'était juste pour voir si vous
m'écoutez vraiment non mais ça c'était
des réminiscences on ne peut rien donc
d'abord achkir les 17000 point tost
deuxièmement il y à des discussions
entre la commission le gouvernement
entre deux rapporteurs et le
gouvernement qui vise à assurer le
financement d'un existant de 7,17 1000
points poste
nous aurons l'occasion tout au long des
débats sur l'article de l'article de
terre de discuter de cette question du
financement
elle est naturellement essentielle il
faut d'abord que l'on sache clairement
et de façon non contestable quel est le
coût de cette mission de la présence
postale a donc expertiser le coutelas
poste nous annonce un chiffre
il est normal et qu'il y ait aussi une
expertise indépendante de ce coup et
nous sommes prêts à accepter les
amendements qui iront dans ce sens et
ensuite nous mettrons au point un mode
de financement qui assure le maintien de
ces dix sept mille points poste à voir
l'ensemble de ses missions
nombre de ces points poste et quelque
chose et qui est tout à fait essentiel
pour toute politique d'aménagement du
territoire et notamment d'aménagement du
territoire rural je souhaite pour
rappeur pouvoir utiliser la poste pour
qu'elle reçoive d'autres services
publics que l'on puisse par exemple dans
un point poste trouver une borne de
visioconférence pour la msa pour la
sécurité sociale ou pour tout autre
service social qui n'existe pas et qui
n'a jamais existé sur ce territoire
bureau il faut qu'à la fois on modernise
la poste et qu'on amène un plus dans les
points poste
il s'agit pas de se contenter de
l'existant il s'agit d'aller plus loin
c'est en tous les cas le but que nous
poursuivons avec ce projet et nous
aurons l'occasion de développer et tout
cela au cours des discussions que nous
lançons pour les assises des territoires
ruraux et à partir de là bâtir une
politique de présence des services
publics sur l'ensemble du territoire et
notamment sur l'ensemble et des
territoires ruraux
voilà ce que je souhaitais rappelé au
moment où l'on aborde lecture de ce
projet de loi relatifs à la poste la
poste service public service au public
présent de façon exceptionnelle sur
l'ensemble du territoire
c'est le but que poursuit le
gouvernement merci monsieur ministre à
paroles dans quelques instants va être
un monsieur christian estrosi ministre
chargé de l'industrie
mais la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président ce président de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs bon
je vais répondre à chacun des 17 orateur
mais on se connaît avec un certain
nombre d'entre vous depuis longtemps
déjà
c'est pas sauvé ça sert à rien de
brandir les les panneaux référendum à un
moment peut se parler quand même droit
dans les yeux je vais mais je je je sais
ce qu'est la politique et je sais je
sais comment et et je ne le conteste pas
l'opposition est dans son rôle
l'opposition est dans son rôle mais
depuis plusieurs années il y en a un
certain nombre d'entre vous sur tous ces
bons qui sont venus me voir
régulièrement dans mon bureau et
notamment lorsque j'étais ministre en
charge de l'aménagement du territoire et
qui à l'époque me disait écoutez
monsieur le ministre
d'autres plus familièrement même sur ses
bancs par mon prénom pour me dire qu'on
me dire voilà je suis en zone blanche
téléphonie mobile j'ai pas l'adsl vous
venait d'inventer les pôles d'excellence
rurale
ça serait vraiment bien que sur la santé
sur la culture sur l'agriculture sur le
sport sur le tourisme sur les loisirs
sur la filière bois sur l'élevage sur un
certain nombre de sujets ou d'autres au
moment du grand débat sur les pôles de
compétitivité
quand il s'agissait d' arbitrer au siat
du 12 juillet 2005
est-ce qu'il en faut 60 est-ce qu'il en
faut 12
vous savez j'ai plein de pme qui en se
regroupant dans mon canton dans ma
circonscription dans mon département et
ont ce décloisonnement avec universités
pourraient permettre de développer plus
rapidement une nouvelle économie sur mon
territoire
comment chercher des solutions
lorsqu ensemble nous avons discuté avec
l'association des maires de france de la
charte des services publics en milieu
rural
tous ces sujets je vous le dis après de
toute façon je sais très bien de quoi
sera fait le débat il y aura un soutien
y aura une opposition et c'est ainsi que
va la vie démocratique mais il est
important de rappeler quand même quand
nous sommes tous des élus locaux et nous
le sommes avec michel mercier et nous
sommes confrontés depuis des années dans
nos responsabilités d'élus locaux aux
mêmes réalités
quelles que soient les territoires sur
lesquels nous nous trouvions je dis bien
aux mêmes réalités
et donc tout soit vous le savez pour
beaucoup d'entre vous ici aussi nous les
avons partagé ensemble ou m'avait invité
quelques fois venir chez vous même
quelquefois et inaugurer des bureaux de
poste dans vos circonscriptions ou dans
vos départements et nous savons à chaque
fois qu'il ya entre le terrain entre la
réalité humaine et entre le débat
politique et politicien quelque chose de
si différent
malheureusement alors les choses sont
ainsi faites mais je peux vous dire que
lorsqu'on m'a confié cette
responsabilité
lorsque le président de la république
lorsque le premier ministre m'ont confié
cette mission il y a quelques mois de
cela
d'occuper cette place avec dans mon
décret d'attribution d'avoir la charge
d'une des plus belles entreprises
publiques de notre pays celle de la
poste après avoir mené tous les combats
que j'ai menés dans mes village et dans
mes canton pour essayer de sauver ici un
tribunal à greffe du tribunal d'instance
une brigade de gendarmerie une
trésorerie
un bureau de poste un bureau de télécoms
tout ça je connais par coeur et je
n'aurais jamais accepté dans les
responsabilités qui sont les miennes de
venir devant le parlement
présenter une réforme postale de cette
nature si au fond moi même j'avais la
certitude que quelque part je mettrais
un tant soit peu
en difficulté le caractère du service
public de la poste
ses missions de service public et le
maintien à 100 % de son statut public à
l'intérieur de cette réforme
je vous le dis avec la force de mes
convictions et avec la force de ma
détermination
saucier tandis maintenant on rentre dans
le débat on rentre dans le débat bien
évidemment il ya un besoin d'explication
vous essayez d'utiliser le spectre de la
privatisation et en même temps je
regrette une chose je regrette une chose
parce que franchement j'en connais là
aussi beaucoup d'entre vous qui ont des
démarches quelquefois voire même souvent
constructive quand il s'agit d'intérêt
général vous venez de suivre la suite du
projet de loi sur la réforme de la poste
pour revoir cette séance notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
à suivre le journal de 18 heures
présenté par emmanuel kessler
merci de votre fidélité et à très
bientôt sur public sénat